speaking with Brazilian newspaper for
this Apollo on Saturday giselle said
quote automatically my body tells me if
what i wanted to do is worth it and i
asked and it asked to stop I respect my
body it is a privilege to be able to
stop so she's had two kids obviously she
still looks unbelievable but don't worry
Brendon you will still be seeing her in
Prince she is still you know she still
represents oral-b whitestrips she still
represents under armour that's a new
contract of hers pinch but I think that
that actually shows you know an amazing
understanding knowledge of her industry
and self-awareness or her to say it's a
privilege to be able to stop because of
course other models you know stop much
early earlier and and and she you know
she has so much money from other
contracts that she can but she deeply
understands that it's a privilege to be
able to make well clearly she's in good
enough shape but you could also say
she's worth what half a billion dollars
at this point it was it really worth 10
grand for her to got that advertising
contract with detail the Brazilian bank
as well